each other
it seems like the World Cup has already
started in this place and Buenos Aires
they're all traveling to Qatar for the
World Cup and this is the last barbecue
before their trip
[Music]
Lorena Rodriguez says most of them have
become experts in finding the most
affordable way to accompany Argentina's
team in Doha
I haven't gone on holiday for two years
saving every peso to buy dollars to be
able to make this trip our dollar is
devalued so it costs more and I will
travel with several stopovers we stay in
the cheapest place but we will be there
exchange rate controls around 14
different types of exchange rates one of
them is known as the dollar Qatar but
because of the taxes that are going to
be imposed on credit cards but all these
people here say that they don't care
that they will do whatever it takes to
make it to the world cup
says that during the last World Cup he
traveled to Russia but had to pay three
times more on his credit card when he
returned because of differences in the
exchange rate
in Russia it happened that we left with
a dollar at 14 and then there was a
devaluation to 21 and I spent everything
and had to replan everything we managed
we are argentines and we're used to
crisis we adapt
had lung cancer three years ago he was a
professional football player and had to
change his life
I had pain in my chest and took
ibuprofen I went to the doctor and there
was a spot they thought it was pneumonia
in the end I had cancer when I had
surgery and woke up I looked at my
father and said if I survive this we are
going to the World Cup
father and son have tickets to watch
other countries but not Argentina they
say living This World Cup together is
their biggest gift
our whole lives changed we have a new
calendar which are his controls that
happen every month and living this has
been a challenge on the economic side on
the personal side we still don't have
tickets to see Argentina but I'm hoping
we will get them
passion for football and Lionel Messi
runs high here fans traveling to Qatar
are leaving all their troubles behind
with one thing in common their support
for the team they love
Buenos Aires